[Musik]
sie leben im Visier Chinas vor ihrer
Haustür die mächtigste Militärmacht der
Welt
die sind eine Diktatur wenn sie dich
angreifen möchten müssen die obersten
Führer nur ein bisschen Alkohol trinken
und den Befehl geben dann greifen sie an
wie lebt es sich auf Taiwan auf einer
Insel auf der viele Angst vor einem
Krieg haben und andere längst mittendrin
sind
längst statt jeden Tag gibt es Angriffe
der cyber-armee wie lebt es sich auf
einer Insel deren Nachbar davon träumt
zur Nummer 1 in der Welt zu werden
politisch militärisch wirtschaftlich
die Aktion ist nur der erste Schritt
danach sollen Japan und die Philippinen
kommen Chinas Macht will die ganze Welt
durchdringen
was noch einem normalen Büro in Taiwans
Hauptstadt Taipeh aussieht ist ein
Kriegsschauplatz hier wollen sie
herausfinden wer es auf Taiwan abgesehen
hat untersuchen jeden Tag mehrere
Cyberangriffe zum Beispiel diesen hier
diese Supermärkte gibt es in Taipei an
jeder Straßenecke im vergangenen Herbst
stand auf dem Bildschirm über der Kasse
wo normalerweise Werbung läuft ganz
plötzlich
kriegstreiberin
eine Botschaft aus China
Nancy Pelosi damals Sprecherin des
US-Repräsentantenhauses besuchte Taiwan
für Chinas Staatsführung die die
demokratische Insel als Teil ihres
Staatsgebiets betrachtet eine
Provokation diese Läden hier prägen das
Stadtbild gibt sie wirklich an jeder
Straßenecke hier wird eingekauft Pakete
abgeholt oder die Stromrechnung bezahlt
diese gehackte Anzeigetafel die
überraschte viele morgens beim Kaffee
holen und war so ganz plötzlich im
Alltag der Leute die Leute merken jetzt
vor allem nachdem Besuch wie verwundbar
unser System ist und was die chinesische
Seite anrichten kann
vorher solche Angriffe kommen Ihre
Antwort immer häufiger aus China von
staatlicher Seite Firmen Privatpersonen
ein Grund für Sie Chinas aggressive
Außenpolitik
you can see that this kind diese
Atmosphäre fördert oder motiviert
anscheinend einige Sicherheitsfirmen
oder Hacker etwas zu machen und zu
zeigen dass sie ihr Land leben dass sie
etwas für China machen wollen
in ihrem Büro befürchten Sie nicht dass
es zu einem Krieg mit China kommen
könnte sie sind mittendrin
der Krieg findet längst statt jeden Tag
gibt es Angriffe der Cyber Armee du
spürst das nur nicht aber die Cyber
Armee macht das jeden Tag
von Taipeh machen wir uns auf den Weg
nach marzow zu Taiwan gehören mehrere
kleine Inseln die direkt vor dem
chinesischen Festland liegen wie leben
die Leute dort mit der Bedrohung
jeden Nachmittag um halb vier öffnet
hier in ihren Obstladen egal was rund um
ihre Insel gerade los ist und dass ihre
Kinder so gerne mit Waffen Spielen liegt
vielleicht auch an dem Ort an dem sie
aufwachsen
[Musik]
ja heute gibt es nicht so viele morgen
kommt die neue Bestellung
im Laden ist immer was los er ist
wichtiger Treffpunkt für die
Nachbarschaft dabei wurde ich ja ihn
hier als zugezogene zunächst kritisch
beugt sie stammt von der taiwanesischen
Hauptinsel hat sich in die maar zur
Inseln und auf den Markt zu Inseln
verliebt hier ihren Partner
kennengelernt die Inselgruppe liegt
direkt vor dem chinesischen Festland und
gehört zu Taiwan ein Überbleibsel des
chinesischen Bürgerkriegs als sich die
unterliegenden Truppen von generalchian
Kai Scheck 1949 von China nach Taiwan
zurückzogen behielten sie die Kontrolle
über diese Inseln als erste
Verteidigungslinie
die Insulaner erzählen uns das Jahr
ihnen inzwischen eine von ihnen ist
sogar die Leitung dieses
gemeinschaftszentrums hat sie übernommen
sie nimmt uns mit zu einem Treffen dass
sie dort für Demenzkranke organisiert
und erklärt uns das Besondere ihrer
Wahlheimat
viele Leute auf Mazo haben nicht nur
Immobilien in Taiwan sondern auch auf
dem chinesischen Festland die können
einfach kommunizieren sprechen die
gleiche Sprache viele haben dort auch
verwandteile
zu Taiwan gehört aber die Beziehungen
zum chinesischen Festland sind viel
enger
deshalb sind sie froh dass es seit ein
paar Wochen endlich wieder eine Fähre
dorthin gibt zweimal am Tag in nur 25
Minuten wegen der corona-pandemie fuhr
die drei Jahre lang nicht
die Passagiere fast nur Taiwanesen
umgekehrt davon China nur kommen wer
enge Verwandte auf nahezu hat ansonsten
verbietet der chinesische Staat das
denn für die kommunistische Führung ist
Taiwan ein Teil von China das
Staatsfernsehen zeigt wie Chinas Armee
die abtrünnige Provinz notfalls mit
Gewalt wieder vereinen will wie es in
der Propaganda heißt seine militärische
Bedeutung als erste Verteidigungslinie
hat nahezu verloren denn Chinas Waffen
reichen längst bis nach Taipei
die Bedrohung bleibt und beunruhigt dann
trank der Grundschullehrer bringt seinen
demenzkrankenvater ins Gemeindehaus und
sagt als erstes er sei anderer Meinung
als die meisten auf nahezu die sind ihm
zu China freundlich er will auf keinen
Fall unter dem Regime der
Kommunistischen Partei leben
die sind eine Diktatur wenn sie dich
angreifen möchten müssen die obersten
Führer nur ein bisschen Alkohol trinken
und den Befehl geben dann greifen sie an
darüber wird nicht diskutiert wenn sie
nicht ganz klar im Kopf sind ist das ein
Risiko für uns
er ist auf nahezu geboren an der
Frontlinie wie er es nennt ist mit der
Bedrohung aufgewachsen
Kriegsschiffe und Kampfflugzeuge
beschäftigen ihn nicht so sehr wie das
was vor ein paar Wochen passiert ist
wir hatten plötzlich keinen
Internetempfang mehr
ein paar Leute sagen das sei Teil des
Kriegs ob das stimmt weiß ich nicht
zurück im Obstladen erzählt uns tjajin
die Geschichte beide Unterseekabel die
nahezu Internet bringen sollen von
chinesischen Schiffen gekappt worden
sein aus Versehen oder Absicht wissen
sie nicht was sie wissen zwei Monate
lang warteten sie auf das
reparaturschiff ersatzempfang über
mikrowellenfunk war schlecht und
wetterabhängig
jetzt sind es 310 Megabyte damals waren
es nur 56 bis 60 Kilobyte
eine SMS schicken dauerte da schon mal
15 Minuten ja ihn verkaufte zu der Zeit
chinesische SIM-Karten inklusive Tipps
für die wenigen Stellen auf der Insel
mit Empfang
wenn es nach ihr geht soll einfach alles
so bleiben wie es ist ihr Mann scherzt
oft wenn China ernst mache würden sie
halt die Flagge wechseln und sonst nicht
weiter merken
das sehen die Soldaten denen sie jeden
Morgen das Obst zur Kaserne bringt wohl
anders 3000 sind auf der Insel
stationiert früher waren es 50.000
general über einer von ihnen er war als
junger Soldat auf malzustationiert und
wird die Zeit nicht vergessen vor allem
einen Tag in den 90er jahren da brachte
das Versorgungsschiff nicht nur essen
Wasser und Öl sondern auch Säcke mit
Plastiktüten sehr dunkle Tüten das waren
Leichensäcke
auch er glaubt das Smartphone nicht mehr
Chinas erstes Ziel sein wird dafür sind
die Inseln zu unbedeutend Chinas
waffenreichen inzwischen viel weiter die
Gefahr für Taiwan macht das noch größer
der erste Schritt danach sollen Japan
und die Philippinen kommen Chinas Macht
will die ganze Welt durchdringen
wir wollen uns anschauen welche Spuren
Chinas Bedrohung auf nahezu hinterlassen
hat Waffen Soldaten Militäranlagen heute
oft nur noch Touristenattraktion zum
Beispiel die Tunnel in denen Taiwans
Armee ihre Versorgungsschiffe versteckte
es ist kalt hier unten und es fühlt sich
irgendwie bedrückend an viele
taiwanesische Soldaten sind beim Bau
dieser Tunnel Ende der 60er gestorben
damals hatten die Leute große Angst dass
China ihre Insel angreifen würde
war damals Oberst in der Armee er zeigt
uns die Anlagen aus der Zeit als die
Insel noch militärisches Sperrgebiet
waren
es gibt mehr als 100 solcher Festungen
auf Markt zu hier guck mal da konnte der
Feind nicht hochklettern hier brauchten
wir also keine Gewehre hier brauchten
wir Kanonen wenn die Schiffe uns
umzingelten zielten wir mit den Kanonen
auf See
kann ich mir vorstellen wie die Insel
aussah als sie noch militärisches
Sperrgebiet war solche Wachposten die
sind heute nur noch für die Touristen
von den 50.000 Soldaten sind noch 3.000
übrig Waffen Strategie und die Art der
Bedrohung haben sich verändert
Frage zeigt uns seine Heimat es gibt
weder Ampeln noch wird gehupt sein Auto
ist nie abgesperrt
er glaubt nicht dass Chinas armeema zu
angreifen wird will das auch nicht
glauben
für ihn sind die Menschen auf beiden
Seiten der Taiwanstraße eine Familie so
nah dass sie sich sehen können
nächsten zum chinesischen Festland liegt
die gauden-insel da sind es nur 9,5 oder
9,6 Kilometer
nach Taipeh sind das fast 200 km die
nahezu-inseln liegen dazwischen zwischen
China und Taiwan mitten im Konflikt das
lassen Urlaubsflair langsamer Rhythmus
und der Pragmatismus der Insulaner
manchmal vergessen allerdings nur bis
zum nächsten Militärmanöver
um auf solche Manöver reagieren zu
können braucht Taiwan Experten wie Lee
fliegen war schon immer sein großer
Traum eigentlich wollte er Pilot werden
doch seine Augen sind zu schlecht
heute ist der 23-Jährige Ingenieur er
arbeitet in einer der besten
drohnenfirmen Taiwans und ist
schließlich doch noch Pilot geworden
Pilot auf Distanz
im Flugsimulator erklärt er uns warum
das ein großer Unterschied ist
wie ein Flugzeug fliegen kann kann nicht
wirklich eine Drohne fliegen das hat mir
ein Flugzeugpilot gesagt
denn der Pilot sitzt hier nicht im
Cockpit sondern steht außerhalb wie beim
echten Drohnen fliegen
Lee merkt sofort dass ich keine
videospielerin bin nach wenigen Sekunden
ist für mich game over
was hier nach Spaß aussieht kann schnell
ernster Realität werden
meine Fähigkeiten einsetzen um meinem
Land zu helfen
Taiwans Regierung pusht die
drohnenbranche des Landes der Krieg in
der Ukraine hat noch mal gezeigt wie
wichtig es ist diese Technologie im
eigenen Land zu haben die Angst das ist
Taiwan ähnlich ergehen könnte und das
aus den muskelspielen des mächtigen
Nachbarn China ernst wird denn die
Kommunistische Partei betrachtet die
demokratische Insel als Teil ihres
Staatsgebiets die Propaganda spricht
immer wieder von Wiedervereinigung
warum eigentlich das wollen wir in der
Hauptstadt Taipeh herausfinden in der
krankheitscheck Gedächtnishalle zusammen
mit den Touristen schauen wir uns den
Wachwechsel an
war in den 30er Jahren einer der
weltweit bekanntesten chinesischen
Politiker er wollte an der Spitze Chinas
stehen und kämpfte im chinesischen
Bürgerkrieg gegen die Kommunisten unterm
Auto doch
1949 endete der Krieg auf dem
chinesischen Festland in dem changai Sex
sich mit seinen Leuten auf die
taiwanesische Insel zurückzog mit dem
Plan das Festland zurückzuerobern die
einen verehren ihn als Helden andere
verbinden mit ihm das Leid dass er den
Taiwanesen angetan hat Kylie gehört zu
den anderen
Gedächtnishalle das nervt die 38-Jährige
denkt wie viele ihrer Generation für sie
ist er in erster Linie verantwortlich
für den Tod 10000er tavanesen
und ich finde einige ältere mögen ihn
ein bisschen zu sehr bewundern ihn ein
bisschen zu viel dass erinnert mich an
Nordkorea
es ist diese offene Sprache die ihre
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer an ihrem
Podcast schätzen
[Musik]
internationalen Nachrichten Podcast der
chinesischsprachigen Welt seit sieben
Jahren machen Kylie und kennen den
Podcast zunächst als Hobby inzwischen
gehört er zu den Top 3 des Landes und
sie machen auch Comedy und Bühnenshows
beide haben in China studiert oder
gearbeitet bis die Freiheit dort immer
kleiner wurde
auch noch Corona und alles hat sich
verändert
Chinas Null kovid-politik mit extremen
Maßnahmen wie Massentests und
zwangsquarantäne veränderte den Blick
vieler Taiwanesen auf den Nachbarn sie
zeigte einmal mehr wie hart die
kommunistische Führung durchgreift um
ihre Ziele zu erreichen
genau darauf will auch drohnenpilot lief
vorbereitet sein seine Firma profitiert
wie einige andere von lukrativen
Staatsaufträgen das Ziel Drohnen
entwickeln die flexibel alles bringen
können Kamera Internet oder Waffen
Drohnen die den Gegner ausspähen oder
sogar Sprengsätze abwerfen können mit
Piloten auf Distanz
der Vorteil der Drohnen ist dass sie
leise sind und für die Nutzer sehr
sicher damit müssen keine echten
Menschen an die Front um Aufklärung zu
betreiben
hier besonders gut fliegen üben können
wenn hier mal was abstürzt ist das bei
den zuckerrollfällen rund rum nicht ganz
so schlimm wie es in der Stadt wäre
die drohnenfirmen profitieren davon dass
Taiwan weltweit führend ist bei
Entwicklung und Produktion von modernen
hochleistungs-chips die brauchen Sie
hier für die Fernsteuerung es geht um
Millisekunden wie lange eine Information
braucht bis sie bei der Drohne ankommt
das ist etwas das eine sehr komplexe
Arithmetik erfordert es braucht diese
schnelle Reaktion wenn es eine Sekunde
länger dauert kann es zum Absturz kommen
daher sind die Chips so wichtig
auf dem Test fällt heute geht alles gut
der Fallschirm bringt den Flieger sicher
zurück hier sind sie sich einig der
größte Konkurrent wenn es um diese
Technik geht ist China
für Kylie und kennen ist China zwar
nicht der größte Konkurrent aber bei
ihren Auftritten oft das größte Thema es
nervt die beiden wenn sie als Chinesen
angesprochen werden
nur weil wir aussehen wie Chinesen heißt
das nicht dass wir Chinesen sind wir
sind teilweise wir haben unseren eigenen
Pass unsere eigene Präsidentin
Demokratie und Wahlen wir wählen den
Präsidenten ich wünschte china könnte
das eines Tages auch
Kylies Großeltern kommen aus China wie
viele auf Taiwan hat auch ihre Familie
enge Verbindungen macht dort Geschäfte
sie selbst spürt diese Nähe nicht mehr
für uns fragen sie ihr Publikum wer
definiert sich selbst als Chinese
niemand und wer als Taiwanese
für uns ist China ein anderes Land es
wäre großartig befreundet zu sein aber
wenn die weiter Kriegsflugzeuge
rüberschicken dann ist das echt ein
schwieriger Nachbar
die Bedrohung gehört für sie zum Alltag
sie sind aufgewachsen mit
militärmanövern und Kampfflugzeugen doch
die Stimmung werde immer angespannter
wenn wir unser Publikum im vergangenen
Jahr gefragt haben ob es einen Krieg
geben könnte dann war die Antwort nein
nicht wirklich wenn wir heute Fragen
heißt es eher vielleicht das ist möglich
Kylie und kennen gehören genau wie
drohnenpilot li zu einer Generation die
einen politischen Graben zwischen sich
und ihren Eltern zieht weil die
Verbindung nach China für sie nicht mehr
so eng ist
zu einer Generation die das Gefühl hat
sich auf einen Krieg vorbereiten zu
müssen den sie nicht will
[Musik]